congratulations professor Weiss thank
you how was the ceremony it was exciting
and I they have a piece by Amy beech
which is something you very rarely heard
here at all because she's a one the very
few women composers and she wrote piano
concertos piano sonatas and you never
hear things from her and all of a sudden
here I come to Sweden and I hear an Amy
beech piece wood of course I didn't know
but it was raving you're interesting it
was wonderful in this team you were the
constructor you've been working on this
experiment for decades did you ever have
moments of doubts yeah yeah everybody
asked me that yeah no no no that has
nothing to do with doubts it's the wrong
question I will tell you what I'll tell
you it no no I'll give you the an answer
but you will I hope accept and that is
that what we do and I'm an experimenter
and most of the people who worked on
this thing that were theorists as well
every day is an interesting day
in other words you're not always
thinking about you know what's going on
in the future and you certainly don't
sit there saying oh my god we haven't
detected gravitational waves yet that's
not what you're thinking about what
you're thinking about is here's this
wonderful circuit that you've just
designed it doesn't work today but you
do a little fixing and it works and
everybody is very happy with that
and the next day there's another thing
that you have to have trying to make it
work and again you're continually busy
with the business of making the
experiment go and making it better and
that's an enormous pleasure and the fact
is that you that keeps you going you
don't think about the end result and the
other piece of it is as long as the
group of people you're working with are
convivial which they are in this case
it's it is a wonderful prospect that
you're working with people you enjoy you
go out when something really works you
go out and have a beer you know I mean
it's a thing you don't think about the
end point and then of course when the
end point happened it was really
wonderful but it wasn't the whole reason
we were doing this we were having fun
and you've got to recognize that I mean
are you familiar with the characteristic
great of course I am yeah yeah yeah I
would want every school kid to have that
yeah I don't give up I'd rather have
that they have fun with the grid yeah
but you yeah but how - how
how do you do that very good what you do
is you teach them you know you find out
very quickly if they want to be somebody
who builds things you make help them
build things you help them design things
so that their inventiveness and their
interest is maintained I mean I'm
talking about experimenters I mean have
a much easier time than people who do
theory theory have a harder time with so
there is this thing that you have built
it's in front of you the children love
that children as the young people love
it in today and it's an accomplishment
and so you know they live with that and
for the next accomplishment and the next
one it's not great it has to be done
through that yes there's of course some
stick to witness yeah but the pact fact
is that if it isn't fun and it isn't
pleasure to do and it isn't interesting
with the other people around you you
tend not to do it and that's the key
thing you see like oh must be like a
second home to you isn't it oh very much
so yeah yeah I'm you made a huge
construction and I am made a small one
for you oh my my a small like a travel
version of LIGO for you my my you made
it yeah look I think you should have a
copy of your second home with you all
the time or the my lord
ah that is wonderful it didn't take 40
years thank you very much oh thank you
for that thank that is the nice little
project you have you I love it
[Laughter]